bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur publ Sénat poursivre dans un instant
les travaux de la commission des
affaires étrangères du Sénat qui est
présidée par le sénateur les républicain
ancien Premier ministre Jean-Pierre
rafarin hier les sénateurs de la
Commission ont auditionné l'un des plus
grands spécialistes du monde arabe du
Moyen-Orient le professeur Henry
Laurence professeur au Collège de France
où il est titulaire de la chair
d'histoire contemporaine du monde arabe
Henry Laurence a été interrogé par les
sénateurs principalement sur trois
points d'abord la crise
israélo-palestinienne va-t-on vers une
troisème Intifada ensuite sur la crise
syrienne et sur la place de Bachar
el-Assad dans le processus de transition
démocratique et enfin la la rupture
entre l'Arabie Saoudite et l'Iran
rupture entre les chiites et les
sunnites tout de suite donc retour à
cette audition qui s'est tenue hier
matin au
Sénat monsieur le professeur vous avez
déjà contribué y compris donc sur le
rapport du président Cambon et à nos
travaux on connaît votre la pertinence
de votre analyse et nous sommes très
intéressés par les échanges que que nous
voudrions avoir sur cet Orient très
compliqué je signale aux uns et aux
autres que cette audition est
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et donc un
enregistrement sera consultable à la
demande sur ce site je signale ce point
pour que tous les orateurs soient bien
toujours informés quand il y a une
retransmission internet puisque nous
avons vu dans un certain nombre de
réunions diplomatiques y compris par
exemple pour les propos de l'ambassadeur
Orlof l'autre jour que un ambassadeur a
été convoqué dans un pays pour expliquer
pourquoi l'ambassadeur devant le Sénat
avait tenu ce type de propos donc c la
vertu d'Internet qui fait que comme cela
il y a une pénétration de nos débats
dans la vie diplomatique très
opérationnelle alors venons-en à ces
débat euh les sujets sont multiples il y
a au moins trois grands euh
écran que nous voudrions essayer de
d'éclairer plus particulièrement le
conflit
israelllo-palestinien des initiatives
récentes ont été prises notamment
français mais on a quand même le
sentiment que les choses continuent à se
déterriorer sommesnous à la veille 3è
antifada cette fois-ci au couteau
comment voyez-vous les choses et et et
comment sortir de ces impasses euh
est-ce qu'un è relance du processus de
paix est
aujourd'hui perceptible à un
horizon saisissable ensuite la crise
syrienne
donc la crise syrienne et le processus
de transition politique comment vous
vous voyez ce ce processus comment la
place de
Bachar alAssad peut se se définir dans
dans ce dispositif complexe dans ces
négociations avec euh l'impact
naturellement des différentes autres
tensions qui ont pu se développer entre
les États-Unis et la Russie entre la
Russie et la Turquie entre l'Iran
l'Arabie Saoudite et cetera et donc ces
complexités
impriqué et puis ce conflit cette
rupture plus exactement entre l'Arabie
Saoudite et l'Iran et peut-être plus
généralement donc entre le monde sunnite
et le monde chiite comment est-ce que
vous d'analyser ces désaccords euh qui
pourrai être des désaccords fondamentaux
ou simplement des
ambitions et des rivalités
euh incompatibl dans sur un plan
régional avec des des
rivalités qui font que les intérêts des
uns des autres l'emportent sur la
situation
elle-même de la Syrie et de sa
confrontation avec daang grand merci
pour votre présence ce que je vous
propose c'est peut-être faire un exposé
initial et qu'ensuite on
pourra avoir un certain nombre de
questions mes collègues sont très
curieux de vous entendre donc peut-être
une quinzaine de minutes une vingtaine
de minutes puis ensuite un débat avec
les membres de notre commission en tout
cas monsieur le professeur nous sommes
très sensibles à votre présence et nous
vous faisons part de notre gratitude
pour
cela je vous remercie monsieur le
président donc on m'a demandé un exposé
peut-être d'abord de cadrage général
avant peut-être de revenir sur les
domaine spécifique que vous
venez
d'évoquer la première chose moi je suis
un historien c'est qu'en gros cette
région dite monde arabe Proche-Orient
Moyen-Orient est dans un système
politique depuis disons la fin des 18e
siècle qui est construit dans un jeu
permanent d'ingérance et d'implication
des puissances locales régionales et
internationales
euh c'est-à-dire que quand vous êtes un
acteur sur cette scène que vous êtes
dans un rapport de force avec des
compétiteurs vous allez faire
nécessairement appel à des forces
extérieures pour compenser un rapport de
force défavoraable et ainsi de suite au
19e siècle par exemple ça pouvait
descendre au niveau d'un
village dans la montagne
libanaise vous pouviez avoir un paysan
drus et un paysan maronite qui se
bagarrait ça provoquait l'intervention
du consul de France qui était protecteur
des maronides du consul d'Angleterre qui
était protecteur des Drus ça remontait à
Constantinople si on narrivait pas à se
mettre d'accord à Beyrouth et ça se
remontait euh à Paris et à Londres si on
n'arrivait pas à se mettre d'accord
à Constantinople de façon générale c'est
dans le code génétique de la
politique régionale Sadam Hin perd la
guerre avec l'Iran il implique les
Occidentaux euh à son venir à son aide
on envoie une escadre dans le golf et
l'intervention occidentale conduit à la
fin de cette guerre mais quand le même
Saddam Hussein
annexe le kouit l'Arabie
Saoudite implique les puissances
occidentales et autes pour créer une
coalition internationale pour reprendre
le C et ainsi de suite donc
fondamentalement tout acteur
euh utilise un réseau d'alliance à
plusieurs niveaux et en particulier pour
construire ces alliances euh les acteurs
développent soit des discours d'intérêt
commun euh bénéfice géopolitique et
cetera l'égye protectrice du canal de
suè et ainsi de suite
soit des raisons idéologiques nous
défendons une culture une position
politique proche de votre bloc euh soit
un appel humanitaire urgent par rapport
à une catastrophe humanitaire en cours
on voit ça par exemple dans la situation
syrienne euh
aujourd'hui donc ça c'est le cadrage
général sur le point le plus récent nous
sommes encore dans les conséquences de
la fin des années
1970 qui ont eu une
recomposition régionale extrêmement
importante alors qu'on était encore en
guerre froide euh c'est donc l'année
1979 qui est l'année clé euh pour la
compréhension des
événements régionaux puisque c'est
l'année de la révolution iranienne de la
création de la République islamique de
téran et à diavra les Occidentaux
longtemps n'ont pas compris l'impleur de
la transformation certes monsieur
bresinski à l'époque a parlé d'un arc de
crise allant de l'Indonésie euh à la
Méditerranée dans lequelle il identifié
dans toutes ses crises en cours des
musulmans euh mais on l'avait encore
perçu euh dans la vision
euh qui était celle de la guerre froide
ainsi commeésident Carter euh a créé une
force d'intervention rapide qui
deviendrare le C et ainsi de suite donc
fondamentalement tout acteur euh utilise
un réseau d'alliance à plusieurs niveaux
et en particulier pour construire ces
alliances les acteurs développent soit
des discours d'intérêt commun euh
bénéfice géopolitique et cetera l'égype
protectrice du canal de Sue et ainsi de
suite
soit des raisons idéologiques nous
défendons une culture une position
politique proche de votre
bloc soit un appel humanitaire urgent
par rapport à une catastrophe
humanitaire en cours on voit ça par
exemple dans la situation syrienne eu
aujourd'hui donc ça c'est le cadrage
général sur le point le plus récent nous
sommes encore dans les conséquences de
la fin des années
1970 qui ont V une
recomposition régionale extrêmement
importante alors qu'on était encore en
guerre froide euh c'est donc l'année
1979 qui est l'année clé euh pour la
compréhension des
événements régionaux puisque c'est
l'année de la révolution iranienne de la
création de la République islamique euh
de téran et à diavra les Occidentaux
longtemps n'ont pas compris l'impleur de
la transformation certes monsieur
bresensski à l'époque a parlé d'un arc
de crise allant de
l'Indonésie à la Méditerranée dans
lequel il identifié dans toutes ses
crises en cours des musulmans euh mais
on l'avait encore
perçu dans la vision
euh qui était de la guerre froide ainsi
commeésident Carter a créé une force
d'intervention rapide qui deviendra
ensuite le
saintcom c'était non pas pour intervenir
contre l'Iran mais pour protéger l'Iran
contre une invasion
soviétique donc il a fallu attendre
1990 pour que les plans de combat de de
sancon commencent à s'intéresser aux
acteurs régionaux comme menace et non
pas contre euh l'Union
euh soviétique
1979 c'est aussi l'invasion soviétique
de
l'Afghanistan et évidemment on va avoir
une double conséquence des événements
1979 euh d'une part la révolution
iranienne a eu une volonté
hégémonique sur l'ensemble du monde
musulman en expliquant que bah ils
avaient réussi que il pouvait prendre en
gros la
direction du monde musulman et en même
temps et montré aux différents
mouvements
islamistes présent dans le monde
musulman que la prise de pouvoir était
possible jusqu'à
1979 aucun islamiste n'avait pris le
pouvoir donc ça pouvait être ce qu'on
aurait pu appeler des les
révolutionnaires sans révolution euh à
partir de 1979 et a bien une raison de
prise de pouvoir ce qui d'ailleurs
déclench immédiatement des véritables
guerres civiles en
7982 en Égypte Irak et Syrie trois
tentatives de prise de pouvoir par les
islamistes et trois
tentatives qui ont été liquidé dans le
sang même si ça conduit à l'assassinat
de Saade euh en 1900 euh
81 mais surtout
cette évolution
hégémonique des siites sur l'islam a
provoqué une
réaction sunnite qui s'est
construite dans le Jad afghan donc avec
notre
soutien il y a une photo célèbre
représentant le président Rean au salon
oval recevant des chefs de laés ristance
afghane en
tenue
afghan
donc ce jihad contre l'Union sonique ce
jihad afghan bon était composé d'une
part d'afghan mais on a vu
arriver des volontaires de l'ensemble du
monde musulman et en
particulier du monde arabe je m'excuse
prèsre certains mais j'utiliserai le
terme technique jusqu'à aujourd'huiz de
brigadiste pour ce genre de volont terre
qui ACC court du monde entier pour
défendre une cause même si ça peut être
estimé injérieux pour les Brigades
Internationales de la
guerre
d'Espagne donc ces brigadistes qui étit
à PE
chvoir et qui était arabe ont construit
une doctrine mortifè et une pratique
politique du Jihad c'estàd qu'il le
faisait moins eux-mêmes qu'il n'en
étaient les doctrinaires ou les
intellectuels il y avait en particulier
des Égyptiens des Saoudiens le fameux
Ben Laden euh et
euh des Palestiniens euh dans ce groupe
après l'effondrement du bloc de l'Est et
de l'Union soviétique ces
jihadistes qui ont estimer peut-être à
tur qu'ils étaient responsables de la
fondrand de l'Union soviétique on
pensait qu'il pour retourné l'arme
contre l'Occident et on est passé du
Jihad
afghan au jihad international dans les
années
90 ce jade
international a
été bon représenté en particulier par
Ben Laden Al-Qaïda donc mais je pense
que l'expression g internationale est
plus
explicite que le terme alceda néanmoins
le terme alceda est intéressant parce
que en réalité je ne sais pas s'il l'a
fait directement mais Ben Lanen a trouvé
ou repris la théorie du foco de tgevara
quand j'ai dit ça régist de BR il était
furieux mais c'est la réalité Régis m'a
dit mais c'est moi qui a inventé la
théorie du foco c'est-à-dire créer des
multiplicités de le combat pour épuiser
l'adversaire impérialiste un peu partout
dans le monde et c'est ce qui a fait
très
sérieusement le jade international en
allumant des fond de combat dans le
caucas en
Bosnie et un peu partout en évidemment
dans un autre contexte au Cachmir et
ainsi de suite et l'on doit
dire que avec une gentillesse
extraordinaire monsieur George deio Bush
lui offert l'Irak euh en
2003 euh et donc là où il y avait pas de
jihadiste il a permis euh Lang au Jad
international de s'engouffrer
euh dans
l'affaire irakienne et dans ce contexte
de l'affaire irakienne euh le jihad
version bladen s'est transformé
progressivement dans une organisation
rivale qui s'est construite mais à
partir de la même expérience qui porte
le nom d'aujourd'hui d'État islamique ou
de DAEs
euh mais la différence c'est que DAEs
fait aussi une politique de
territorialisation politique en faisant
la conquête d'un territoire ce que au
contraire le jihad version Ben Laden lui
c'était la multiplication des
fronts un peu partout mais je pense que
nous aurons revenir sur ces questions
l'autre point j'ai pas le temps
d'exliciter ici c'est évidemment
l'effondrement de l'autoritarisme
arabe en 2011 avec le fameux printemps
arabe le printemps arabe est
probablement la seule révolution dans
l'histoire qui n'est pas fa au nom
d'unethopie mais au nom d'une volonté de
normalité
les gens qui se sont révoltés en 2011 de
se sont révoltés pour avoir une vie
normale dans une société libre et à peu
près démocratique euh avec évidemment
l'adaptation aux réalités euh
culturel local donc le souhait profond
des populations c'est bien ce souhait de
normalité euh ça n'a pu fonctionner dans
les premiers mois de
2011 que parce qu'il y a eu comme
suspension de la géopolitique et
donc le fait que les acteurs étaient
purement
locaux mais dès l'intervention
occidentale qui était à mon avis
justifié en Libye
euh la notion géopolitique et revenu
c'est-à-dire qu'on est revenu dans un
jeu d'implication et d'ingérence et puis
ensuite ça a été la catastrophe syrienne
absolument
absolue qui est que à partir du moment
où le régime de Bachar al-Assad est
parti dans une logique éradicatrice de
son opposition
euh l'opposition ne pouvait devenir
qu'une opposition armée et depuis
2011 l'affaire sérielle fonctionne comme
un trou
noir qui appe tout l'environnement
régional puis internationale
euh ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui bah vous
avez une coalition occidentale une
coalition arabe et une coalition menée
par les Russes avec le soutien de l'Iran
mais à chacun dans chaacune des
coalitions euh chacun regarde son pseudo
allier avec
euh méfiance
euh donc c'est vraiment cette
catastrophe qui est
absolu et dont nous payons les
conséquences de façon
dramatique sur deux choses bon la
première
évidemment c'est la propagation des
attentats du Jihad international cette
fois-ci version état islamique et non
plus version Kaida dans le monde
occidental avec dans une certaine mesure
ce qu'on a pu appeler avec un humour
noir une érisation du terrorisme
euh c'està dire qu'on a même plus besoin
de créer un réseau de préparer des gens
pour organiser une attaque on suscite
l'attaque par de la
propagande sans qu'il ait connexion
nécessaire avec un centre qui donne des
ordres d'ù la notion d'ubérisation
euh du terrorisme les attentats de Paris
c'était pas une libérisation c'était
préparé à l'avance mais ce qui s'est
pariss par exemple à Marseille il y a de
jours euh c'est une hbérisation
euh du euh terrorisme donc ça nous coûte
très cher euh pour nous-mêmes pour nos
proches pour notre sécurité pour notre
économie
et ainsi de suite la seconde
chose c'est que l'ensemble des conflits
régionaux euh IR Syrie plus tous les
conflits annexes
euh a provoqué un départ massif de
population et ces m massif de population
c'était tout à fait prévisible moi je
l'ai énoncé des
201223 et on a été apparemment surpris
de les voir arriver en 2015
mais c'était déjà clair il y a 2 ans
queon allait voir ce déclenchement de
millions de personnes qui fuit euh la
région ces millions de personnes qui
fuitent la région nous savons bah qui
nous pose des problèmes parce que d'un
côté nous
avons une situation humanitaire
catastrophique des scènes épouvantables
qui nous arrivent en particulier de la
Méditerranée mais de l'autre côté nous
avons pour des raisons qui ne sont pas
nécessairement condamnables un rejet MIF
de grande partie des populations
européennes de
l'arrivée de ces
migrants alors qu'est-ce que nous
enseignent ces migrants bon évidemment
la première chose c'est que les gens
fuent les zone de
guerre c'est classique mais pourquoi ils
sont partis en 2015 et pas en 2013 pour
la zone syrienne c'est qu'en 2013 ils
avaient encore quelques espérances que
il y aurait un retour à l'ordre un
rééquilibre social en 2015 les gens
partent parce qu'ils n'ont plus
d'espérance
euh sur place mais ça touche même les
zones qui ne sont pas en
guerre j'ai été très frappé il y a
quelques semaines il y a eu une famille
de la banlieu sud de
Beyrou qui a perdu la moitié de ses
membres dans un
naufrage en
Méditerranée euh bon on les a ramené au
Liban les pauvres mais c'était quand
même significatif qu'une famille entière
venant de la borlieu Sud qui est encadré
par le Hezbollah qui est donc une
société extrêmement
structurée soit parti à prendre les
risques d'une traversée clandestine de
la Méditerranée en période automnale
c'est-à-dire en période de mauvais temps
en
Méditerranée donc les gens veulent une
meilleur ça c'est ce que veut le peuple
si j'ose dire massivement dans la région
et je crois que l'une des clés de la
migration actuelle c'est justement la
même chose que pour le printemps arabe
c'est-à-dire la volonté d'avoir une vie
normale mais avec le constat terrifiant
qu'on ne peut plus avoir une vie normale
dans le pays dans lequel on réside je
crois que j'ai fait mes 20 minutes
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
monsieur le professeur
Gor demande la parole et il là merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
professeur vous avez dit au tout début
de votre propos qu'au fond une large
part de la situation dans la région
était liée à l'intervention sollicité ou
non d'un som de puissance qu'on aurait
qualifié par le passé de colonial qui
sont aujourd'hui des puissances
européennes ou occidentales est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que ces
puissances ont tiré la leçon et que la
manière dont elles interviennent
aujourd'hui dans la région répond à un
esprit de responsabilité ou est-ce
qu'ell ne sont que le prolongement des
préoccupations antérie d'ailleurs d'un
partage d'influence politique
géopolitique économique commerciale
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment au
fond que ce dessine dans l'esprit de
ceux aujourd'hui qui sont à à la
manœuvre sur les opérations militaires
qui sont décidées en Irak et en Syrie
quelque chose qui correspond à une autre
vision de la région et de son évolution
et pas simplement le rétablissement d'un
minimum d'ordre si possible sur lequel
il garderait une influence en clair
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que c'est ce qui
c'est une vision de cette région qui
tienne compte à la la fois de l'attente
des populations comme vous l'indiquiez
des phénomènes que produisent les
guerres qui se sont déroulé c'est-à-dire
d'une tendance à la morcellisation de
ces territoires une difficulté à assurer
leur intégrité territoriale qui explique
l'attitude de nombreux États qui ont
évidemment des préoccupations
contradictoire qui veulent s'associer à
une démarche éventuellement de lutte
contre l'organisation état islamique
mais qui derrière ont des préoccupations
de pas avoir émerger qui un état kururg
qui une partition de sa propre de son
propre territoire j'aimerais votre
sentiment sur sur ce point deuxième
question très rapide selon vous quelle
est la nature exacte de l'organisation
état islamique on a on l'a qualifié de
différentes manières des barbares des
fascistes
islamiques elle a une dimension
politique est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on
peut caractériser cette dimension
politique elle intervient dans le
prolongement de la crise du nationalisme
Arab est-ce qu'il y a un lien qu'on peut
établir ou est-ce qu'il faut se garder
de ce genre d'interprétation et enfin
dernier point la crise aujourd'hui a mis
de côté depuis quelques temps l'affaire
palestinienne sur lequelle vous avez
beaucoup travaillé est-ce qu'on peut
considérer c'est le sentiment qu'on en a
quand on regarde la situation de la
région qu'elle est désormais marginale
qu'elle est périphérique dans l'esprit
des différents acteurs est-ce que c'est
votre sentiment
oui monsieur le professeur vous nous
aider à décrypter une carte éminemment
complexe car une multiplicité d'acteurs
se superpose et interagissent les uns
contre les autres et finalement
l'actualité évolue à une telle vitesse
que il y a un mois on aurait peut-être
pas tenu les mêmes propos quand on voit
par exemple ce qui est en train de
démarrer de se passer ou de de se
poursuivre entre l'Arabie Saoudite et
l'Iran pendant très longtemps toute
cette région du monde était été dominé
par des régimes laïques bassistes je
pense à l'Irak à la Syrie qui au moins
avait pour conséquence d'assurer une
forme de paix même si c'était pas un
exemple de démocratie or de plus en plus
la dimension religieuse a transformé un
petit peu les choses et on le voit bien
dans cette affaire euh qui qui secoue
l'Arabie et l'Iran et dont on dit bien
que ce n'est que la répétition ultime du
conflit entre chit et sunnite donc en
quelque sorte une
primauté du religieux sur la politique
comment voyez-vous l'évolution de ces
rapports puisque ce sont quand même deux
in deux poids lourds de la
région possédant de nombreux moyens y
compris économiques et j'aurais aimé
votre sentiment aussi sur l'évolution
d'un autre acteur qui est la Turquie
pour décrypter un petit peu la la
manière dont vous voyez le rôle et
l'intervention de ce pays dans la
géopolitique de cette région
oui professeur merci de votre exposé qui
nous permet de remettre des choses en
perspective dans un contexte extrêmement
fluctuant et et très difficile à
appréhender vous êtes beaucoup intéressé
au au la question palestinienne vous
intéressez aux relations entre Israël et
Palestine dans une vision de durée
est-ce que vous pensez que dans le
contexte actuel où le processus de paix
est qu'on puisse dire au point mort euh
au regarde des événements qui se passe
actuellement à Jérusalem est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a un risque
d'infiltration de je ne sais pas quel
est le mot de récupération euh de daesh
de la cause palestinienne par daesh
pardon de la cause palestinienne c'est
ma première question deè question sans
vous demander de lire dans le mar de
café quelle évolution présagez-vous de
la crise actuelle entre l'Arabie
Saoudite et l'Irak
merci je vais recorrig moi-même vous
inquiétez pas donc la première question
sur l'attitude des grandes puissances en
une bonne sal je crois que la question
se pose pas en ces terme parce qu'elles
sont en même temps
indispensables je veux dire nous
souffrons autant de
l'interventionnisme de la période de
George Debot buou que du non
interventionnisme de la
période du président président Obama
dans la mesure où euh ce jeu
d'ingérance et
d'implication ne peut fonctionner
correctement que si ça crée une sorte de
régulation ce qu'au 19e siècle on
appelait les congrès européens euh Paris
Berlin euh et cetera euh les entretiens
des deux superpissances à l'époque euh
de la guerre froide et cetera et ce dont
nous souffrons fondamentalement c'est
une absence de régulation et la
catastrophe a été de
quand les présidents des États-Unis
s'est retiré après avoir dit qu'il y
avait des lignes rouges et que il n'a
rien fait ou il a a saisi la porte de
sortie en quelque sorte que lui
proposait la Russie c'est-à-dire on
inspecte les armes chimiques ce qui
revenait à autoriser le président Bachar
al-Assad à massacrer sa population
partout les moyens sauf des armes
chimiques euh c'est ça le message qu'on
a envoyé
euh en 2013 c'est si vous voulez quand
vous poussez dans le retranchement les
gens de la région ils montrent combien
ils sont pris dans leur contradiction il
y a une quinzaine d'années j'avais
organisé un colloque avec la branche
culturelle de haszbollah j'avais comme
président de séance le numéro 2 du
haszbollah le Cher alkassem on m'avait
demandé de parler de de la question de
l'Europe et de la Palestine j'ai donc
énuméré toutes les erreurs et
catastrophes que l'Europe a pu faire sur
le sujet depuis de siècles et puis
ensuite je leur ai dit mais vous voulez
qu'on intervienne encore et là ils
étaient est très embêté
euh parce qu'en fait il souhait qu'on
intervienne hein puisqu'on est justement
dans ces jeux euh d'ingérence euh
ou d'implication
euh disons que c'est dans le code
génétique on ne peut pas ne pas ne pas
avoir des ingérences et des implications
dans la région je dis souvent à mes
étudiants que le jour o on cessera
d'utiliser le terme Moyen-Orient qu'on
parlera d'Asie occidentale comme le fait
l'enu à ce moment là ce sera la
démonstration qu'il y a plus de conflit
euh dans cette région du monde puisque
le concept de Moyen-Orient est un
concept politique en ce qui concerne
sunit et chiit il est évident évidemment
qu'il y a des héritages théologique et
des passés douloureux un peu équivalent
à ce qui peut être catholique et
protestant dans l'histoire européenne
que l'Islam a connu l'équivalent des
guerres de religion
à peu près à la même période que les
guerres de religion en Europe
c'est-à-dire du 16e ou 18e siècle pour
le prochorient c'était les fameuse
guerre entre l'Iran chiit et l'Empire
ottoman sunit au 19e siècle vous avez
plutôt eu des tentatives écuméniques ou
concordistes surtout à la fin du 19e
siècle entre ces deux
branches de l'islam et là ça renvoie
c'est un autre sujet à la question du
réformisme musulman dans sa branche
moderniste vous avez eu un concordisme
entre Sunn et chit mais dans sa branche
disons conservatrice fondamentaliste qui
donne la salafie les salafite
d'aujourd'hui au contraire la distance
s'est accrue dans les années 1950 dont
le monde arabe les chit étaient les plus
pauvres et étaient la clientèle de base
du Parti communiste euh au Liban ou en
Irak
euh c'était les chites qui formaient la
base sociale des partis communistes qui
étaient souvent encadré par des
intellectuels chrétiens
euh ce qui d'ailleurs a amené justement
la réaction politique du haut Clerg
chiit en Irak qui est entré en politique
non pas contre l'impérialisme occidental
mais contre la propagande communiste euh
dans la base
sociale des
religieuxit ce qui a donc amené ensuite
les mécanismes qui ont conduit à la
révolution iranienne de 1970 qui est
plus qu'une révolution iranienne
puisquelle a aussi inversant libanis et
un versant iraakien mais je dis que
c'est plus une réaction au départ contre
la rivalité communiste que contre
l'Occident qui a amené cette entrée en
politique des religieux chit c'est pour
ça qu'on peut pas parler nécessairement
enfin d'e
essence euh conflictuelle il est évident
que dans la région actuellement tout ce
qui est religieux et politique et tout
ce qui est politique et religieux euh
ça c'est une chose que ce soit chrétien
juif ou musulman euh c'est
une réalité c'estàd qu'il y a confusion
des deux univers et nous n'y pouvons
rien sinon évidemment euh le regretter
évidemment ça construit des bases
identitaires pour les groupes d'un côté
et de l'autre côté ben ça renvoie à des
histoires je fais toujours une
comparaison si un jour nous avions une
raison quelconque pour faire la guerre à
la Grande-Bretagne nous serions en train
d'hurler dans les rues de Paris ils ont
brûlé jeun d'Arc c'està-dire qu'on
mobilise le
passé et des Affaires religieuses pour
euh des euh actions euh politiques euh
pour la version palestinien bah vous
avez je crois que les Palestiniens ont
fermé dossier ils croient plus en
processus de paix
euh fondamentalement euh la question
qu'on se pose en Israël et en Palestine
c'est savoir si l'Autorité palestinienne
va survivre dans les mois à venir ou si
elle va survivre à la disparition
physique euh de président de l'Autorité
euh palestinienne qui a déjà 80 ans
qui bon é tellement bonne santé mais je
veux dire il n'a pas été réélu depuis
une dizaine d'années donc c'est disparaî
quelle
légitimité il y aura à cette Autorité
palestinienne
euh et de façon générale elle a perdu
ses bases sociales bien que les gens
accept encore dans la mesure où elle
fournit des services euh à la population
et le rceptacle de l'aide étrangère mais
elle n'a plus
de soutien politique euh dans la
population ce en quoi les
Palestiniens semblent espérer
aujourd'hui
euh c'est ah bah d'utiliser nouvelle
gamme d'armes ce qu'ils ont très peu
utilisé jusqu'ici qui serait un peu en
quelque sorte un mélange de procédure
juridique internationale et d'appel au
boycott des produits israélien et c'est
en ce sens la campagne BDS est
extrêmement
importante mais là aussi ça va interagir
avec nous d'ailleurs on a vu
récemment un arrêt de la Cour de
cassation qui pose beaucoup de problèmes
en ce qui qui concerne ces questions euh
de euh boycotte en ce qui concerne
l'état islamique et le conflit
palestinien bah pendant longtemps le
Jihade international ne pouvait pas
accéder en Palestine parce que il y
avait une barrière qui était celle de
rebollah euh le resbollah était il faut
bien comprendre que le jihad et et et
les shit c'est pire que entre
euh ENF l'ennemi numéro 1 du gade
international ce sont les chiites
ensuite vous avez les juifs et les
croisés
euh donc paradoxalement le Hezbollah
avait interdit tout accès au jihad
international à à la
frontière palestinienne ce qui faisait
qu'il y avait des jihadistes dans le
nordliban dans la région de Tripoli dans
le Racard mais il en a jamais eu au
Liban sud parce que ils étaient pas Perm
d'entrer en lib Sud c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui évidemment les fondrements
Syriens fait que maintenant vous avez
des jihadistes à proximité du Golan euh
alors est-ce que ce sont des vrais des
pas vrais est-ce que ce sont des gens
enfin c'est toujours compliqué pour
identifier des groupes qui se battent en
série mais pour la première fois Israël
a un contact direct avec le Gad
international c'est en territoire c'est
et puis maintenant vous en avez aussi
dans le Sinaï
euh d'où
euh le fait que ces jihadistes du Sinaï
quelles sont leurs relations avec le
Hamas elles sont
complexes parce que le Hamas dans la
bande de Gaza lui élimine les
jihadistes parce que ce sont des rivaux
politiques euh et donc la grande peur de
la M S trouvé de plus radical que lui et
donc il mène une r prtion de faire dans
la bande de Gaza contre toute apparition
de mouvement jihadiste ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'a pas des relations
compliquées avec les jidadistes du Sinaï
qui font du trafic divers avec lui dans
cette situation mais donc en effet
l'État islamique enfin le jihadisme a
atteint maintenant la frontière de la
Palestine ce qui était pas le cas il y a
quelques
années bien mes chers collègues j'ai
beaucoup de demandes de parole alors
essayer de faire vite joseette duu merci
monsieur le Président merci professeur
euh dans cette Asie occidentale
puisqu'il faut l'appeler comme ça
maintenant vous avez bien rappelé la
responsabilité puissance
occidentale dans leurs différentes
ingérances au cours de
l'histoire alors on mélange toutes les
notions à juste titre de peuple de de
nation d'état de territoire et si on
remet les choses dans l'ordre parce que
pour avoir un état il faut un peuple une
nation sur un territoire j'ai envie de
vous poser quelques questions la
première que reste-t-il du nationalisme
syrien si on voulait reconstituer l'État
syrien deuxièmement il y a un territoire
curde un peuple tur kurde et des
divisions ce qu' pourrait-il s'achever
une nouvelle fois sans que les CDES n'ai
rien y compris la portion du
territoire syrien dominé par le PID
troisièmement DAEs s'est pas trompé
d'entrer ils ont dit que c'est un état
islamique du Levant c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne voulons pas retenir
cette notion d'état ce conflit
pourrait-il se terminer si on ne radique
pas daesh par l'existence d'un état
résiduel comme l'accepterait bien fort
probablement si on liit entre les lignes
à la fois la Turquie et la Russie et
enfin en ce qui concerne la Palestine on
a tout il suffit de le reconnaître
l'état c'est il faut pas attendre la
mort de Mahmoud Abbas comment
contraindre
netanahou Alain
Joyandet merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le professeur pour votre
votre exposé très très éclairant
j'ai retenu deux ou trois choses de ce
que vous dans ce que vous avez
dit on a autant souffert de l'action de
de Monsieur bouche que de l'inaction de
Monsieur Obama ensuite vous avez dit
tout ce qui est religieux et politique
tout ce qui est politique et religieux
ensuite vous avez dit par rapport à à
l'histoire ENF au fond c'est dans nos
notre interventionnisme est dans nos
gênnes et quand on n'y va pas on nous le
demande donc c'est vraiment une
situation très très compliquée que vous
exp expliquer d'une manière très simple
avec votre vérité
euh et donc merci pour cette cet
éclairage mais comp tenu de tout ça je
voulais vous poser une question mais
vous avez déjà un peu répondu une
question assez simple au fond
aujourd'hui comme vous avez cette vision
et cette analyse ces
certitudes si vous étiez conseiller de
de l'Occident ou conseiller du président
de la République française vous lui
conseilleriez de faire
quoi Alan Erie
oui professeur je voulais vous poser une
question sur les relation avec la
Palestine mais ça a été fait par mes
collègues mais ma 2ème question et quel
risque
courtt-on de voir le le djihadisme
s'étendre d'une façon beaucoup plus
importante sur toute la partie du
Maghreb Tunisie Maroc et Algérie et plus
particulièrement l'inquiétude concerne
l'Algérie à partir du moment où nous
risquons d'arriver dans une période un
peu plus instable en Algérie avec la
chute du prix du pétrole qui s'accélère
donc une baisse des ressources et des
des difficultés sûrement sociale en
Algérie avec des ressources moindes pour
mettre en place une politique sociale
deuxièmement le risque de voir la
succession du président
bouteflica peut-être s'ouvrir dans des
Alés relativement proches et à ce
moment-là créer aussi une période
d'incertitude en Algérie voire
d'instabilité et est-ce qu'on a des
craintes de voir justement l'État
islamique daesh s'engouffrer dans cette
brèche avec des conséquences graves bien
entendu pour tout l'Occident puisque je
suis persuadé que nous devons nous
Européens avoir une politique au niveau
de de tout ce qui est le portour de la
Méditerranée on sait qu'on a déjà nombre
Ré élection dans certaines organisations
internationales autour du forum
méditerranéen et de coopération avec les
pays de l'Afrique du
Nord merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Professeur merci pouros
votre intervention et d'éclairer notre
commission euh vous avez situé l'année
79 comme une année clé puisque vous avez
souligné que c'est la première fois
qu'un état islamique se créa ça a créé
aussi des réactions en chîne et en
particulier des réactions sunnites
euh il y a eu dans la première série des
intervention plusieurs de mes collègues
sont revenus sur la question de l'Arabie
Saoudite et de l'Iran et vous n'avez pas
répondu à à ce point-là j'aimerais bien
vous entendre sur votre sentiment sur la
résolution de cette difficulté de de
rapprochement dans leur politique
internationale de ces deux pays j'ai
compris que évidemment l'ingérance vous
semblait être un élément incontournable
donc de cette ingérence pour essayer de
reconstituer en quelque sorte une
logique d'action dans un dans une de
paix vous semble-t-elle à court terme
envisageable et comment vous voyez
comment vous vous projetez sur ces
sujets dans ces relations entre ces deux
pays clés sur cette zone
géographique merci
barizar bon
pour c'est on est à peu près maintenant
dans la situation de l'Europe de la
guerre de 30 ans d'une gure de tous
contre
tous avec des violences extrêmement
locales parce que il n'avait plus de
force centrale euh vousz y compris du
côté de ce du régime de Bachar alhassad
ce n'est plus qu'un groupement de Milic
et enfin c'est un autre groupement de
Milic et de façon générale chacun des
acteurs tend à faire du nettoyage
ethnique dans la zone dans
lequel il se trouve c'est donc pour ça
que la situation devient vraiment
absolument
euh
catastrophique il y'y a pas de il n'y a
pas un pouvoir central syrien porteur
d'un projet syrien actuellement il y a
un chef de gang mafieux Bachar
alAssad qui entraî avec lui dans sa
perte sa communauté d'origine qui est la
communauté alawiite et les chrétiens qui
l'a
clientélisé euh et de l'autre côté vous
vous avez un agrégat de force local qui
peuvent changer de
discours et de référence en fonction des
gens qui leur apportent des financements
euh et des armes les seuls qui ont
encore un projet syrien c'est
l'opposition syrienne en
exil mais justement elle est pas sur le
terrain
euh en ce qui concerne Iran Arabie
Saoudite évidemment
euh
l'Arabie Saoudite elle a toujours été
paranoïque des sa création
euh sous sa forme actuelle puisque nous
sommes au 3e état saoudien en 2 siècles
et compenu justement qu' en a deux qui
ont été détruits au 19e siècle on
comprend que les saoudias euh ont
mémoire de leur fragilité et en ce sens
là que les fondateur de l'Arabie
Saoudite actuelle c'està-dire le père
fameux bensar en Occident
a toujours pensé que l'Arabie Saoudite
ne pouvait fonctionner que s'il avait
une protection étrangère d'abord la
Grande-Bretagne dans une certaines
mesurees et ensuite les États-Unis après
1945 et de façon plus général la
stratégie de l'Arabie saoudite a été une
stratégie de clientalisation ou de
mercenarisation de ses soutiens
extérieurs alors alors en gros l'un des
moyens par lequel on se on se paye des
protecteurs c'est en leur achetant des
armes plus on achète des armes plus les
protecteurs viendront vous
protéger et ça c'est une Vig saudienne
en plus ça donne une commission de 5 à
10 % de 15 % pour la famille royale ENF
ça c'est dans les propos que j'aurais
pas dû mettre puis que ça va être sur
internet donc ça c'est les mécanismes
fondamental de la politique saoudienne
l'Iran bah c'est un peu la même chose
ont un sens puisque s'il y a pas eu deux
états iraniens détruits au 19e siècle il
y a eu un siècle trois invasions de
l'iranant la Première Guerre mondiale
durant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et durant la guerre Irak Iran donc
indépendamment d'un mouvement
révolutionnaire on peuté qualifier le
régime iranien d'aujourd'hui de
termidorien l'équivalent un peu du
directoire de la Révolution française
mais un directoire qui durera sans
Bonaparte euh mais je vous rappelle
c'est un directoire qui envahissait la
Hollande l'Italie et ainsi de suite donc
euh la volonté iranienne de se projeter
sur les rives de la Méditerranée des
acteurs en Syrie d'être un acteur en
Palestine et cetera c'est un peu une
stratégie je propulse euh les conflits
les plus loin possibles de mon
territoire comme ça ça occupe les autres
et mon territoire devient moins
vulnérable c'est la même raison qui
conduit aussi l'Iran qui a été envahi
plusieurs fois de chercher une solution
éventuelle dans
l'armement nucléaire et ceci évidemment
dépasse la question des régimes euh en
place
euh en Iran
euh du coup
bah vous avez eu la défection américaine
dans certaine mesure
euh pour l'Arabie
Saoudite et ses alliers euh l'accord sur
le nucléaire était une trahison
américaine donc le paradoxalement ça a
donné à l'Arabie Saoudite une ouverture
enfin une plus grande marche d'action
pour la première fois elle agit toute
seule ça qui avec le changement de roi
au début de l'année l'n dernière
l'Arabie a parce que structurelle le
discours saoudien était toujours
d'apparaître avoir agi comme
contrat en 1980 a expliqué que c'était
les Américains et les Iraquiens qui
l'ont
contre tandis que ce qui s'est passé
avec le changement de droit c'est que
l'Arabie saoudite a attaqué tout de
suite sans être contrat alors il faut
dire que l'Iran il a vraiment mis de
l'huile sur le
feu quand vous avez des responsables
iraniens qui ont annoncé que après que
l'Iran contrôle Damas Beyrouth et
Baghdad maintenant ils avaient
Sana c'estàd que la 4e capitale arabe
était tombée dans leur main
euh évidemment la réaction a été
violente de l'autre côté et actuellement
l'Arabie Saoudite est en train de
remobiliser toutes les instances arabes
à son service pour affronter l'Iran donc
on a dans le paradoxe qui est que la
accord sur le nucléaire qui était censé
pacifier la région accélère au contraire
les tensions et les
violence régionale alors tout ça
évidemment dans une situation régionale
où l'économie s'effondre puisque la Rand
pétrolière
euh s'effondre il y avait un article
très excellent ce matin dans le New York
Times qui disait comment on va pouvoir
continuer à combattre contre l'État
islamique
quand les curdes et les Iraquiens n'ont
plus d'argent dans leur caisse
euh et la même chose pour les Russes les
Russes ils ont besoin
d'urgent d'un règlement politique de la
question syrienne euh parce que ça leur
coûte entre 4 et 10 million de dollars
par jour
euh c'est affaire or comme l'économie
russe elle aussi sur le même impact que
les autres ils pourront pas
éternellement financer cette guerre en
série d'où le fait que les Russes
poussent un règlement
euh politique bon en essayant
d'affaiblir la partie de l'opposition
pour l'amener évidemment à iné euh dans
le règlement il y avait un autre point
de
question l'Algérie je suis pas compétent
là je suis spécialiste de l'Orient arabe
plus que du Maghreb je travaille sur le
maghreb colonial mais pas sur le Magreb
indépendant donc je n'oserai pas
répondre euh je voudrais simplement
revenir à un point j'ai pas eu le temps
évidemment d'expliciter sur les
curiosités du Gad international le Gad
international est la rencontre
incongrue des destructions des
structures tribales qui vont du Pakistan
euh à la Méditerranée si vous
regardez la carte euh du Jihad vous
voyez euh que ça cor ça part des zones
tribales pakistanaises et ça va jusqu'à
la Mauritanie et que c'est toujours en
espace de population tribale euh que euh
le Jad se construit se territorialise
mais paradoxalement là on partle ces
gens qui sont dans les tribus recrutent
les brigadistes des banlieux de
l'Occident
euh donc c'est c'est une rencontre
totalement incongrue qui passe par un
maniment extraordinaire euh de
l'Internet des
images et cetera c'est c'est extrêmement
curieux je veux dire il y a une maîtrise
absolue de la communication d'acom euh
alors qu'en même temps on est dans des
structures sociales les plus
archaïques bien Paris sacin merci
beaucoup Monsieur professeurci Merci
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
professeur pour votre exposé tout à fait
intéressant moi je voulais revenir sur
je voulais évoquer la relation
américano-saoudienne qui a démarré en 45
sur un accord entre les Saou et
Roosevelt sur un pétrole pas cher et sur
la protection de la de la tribu des Saou
est-ce que vous pensez pas
qu'aujourd'hui s'est remis en question
avec l'exploitation du gaz de schiste
aux États-Unis et l'accord trouvé à
téran sur le nucléaire ne pensez-vous
pas qu'il y ait un pivotement de de la
relation américano
saoudienne le premier point le deuxème
point sur la dimension religieuse on
assiste à à des chistes
des un chiisme puissant
théologiquement et un sunnisme alors
qu'il est minoritaire et un sunnisme
majoritaire qui est faible
théologiquement et qui qui est faible
qui est faible théologiquement et qui
est virussé par la wahabisation de
l'Islam alors d'cun p qu'il y a un
rapport avec la guerre de succession et
qu'on voudrait refaire un kerbal à 2
pour la pour la pour le leadership de de
l'islam et vous ne pensez pas que le
pivotement américain le premier point
pivotement américain et deuxièmement le
regard que nous occidentaux portons sur
le wabisme avec les conséquences que ça
fait jusque dans nos
banlieux ce ne serait pas une faille
dans la maison des Saou une première
faille dans la Maison des
Saoud merci jés
jordin
professeur merci de des réponses
brillantes que vous apportez à nos
interrogations moi je souhaiterais
simplement dresser un constat à la
sortie de la guerre un grand rêve la
création donc de l'État
d'Israël la création d'un État
palestinien donc indépendant et au-delà
de ça regard qui me
semble porteur de perspective dans un
devenir et aussi de doute et
d'interrogation c'est-à-dire un statut
particulier pour
Jérusalem puisque c'était donc le corpus
seporatum sous contrôle donc
international quand on voit aujourd'hui
la situation telle qu'elle est avec un
peuple quasiment assiégé avait des murs
qui s'érigent pour pouvoir séparer les
populations entre donc palestinien donc
et israélien mais on est loin de ce que
nous avions souhaité je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on entend pas assez la
communauté internationale et je crois
qu'il est grand temps de de bien montrer
que c'est pas du tout cela que nous
souhaitions et qu'à un certain moment
donné lorsqu'on voit comment Israël
aujourd'hui bon la situation dans
laquelle il est il n' il ne peut que
jouer le temps et jouer la montre pour
éviter que la solution à deux étapes
puisqu'on le voit avec donc le le le le
l'occupation des des territoires qui
s'accélèent et qui continue hein c'est
quelque chose je crois aujourd'hui
contre le nous devons nous nous élever
la création de ces états elle a été un
moment symbolique on a voulu donner des
gages et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on a
ben on a l'échec d'une volonté
internationale qui s'est qui s'est faite
le jour jour au sorti de la guerre alors
est-ce que ne vous ne pensez pas
monsieur le professeur que peut-être
revenir puisque quand on voit la
situation de Jérusalem je ne reviendrai
pas sur les épisodes de l'esplanade des
mosquées et cetera que nous avons tous
en mémoire et les attentats qui se
produisent quotidiennement peut-être
est-il venu le temps de redire que ces
solutions qui paraissent lointaines dans
le temps elles sont peut-être
d'actualité merci que je réponde à ces
deux questions qui revient sur une
réponse que j'ai pas faite tout à
l'heure c'est la question de vraiment à
rond hein qu' m'avez posé moi je
répondrai en bout temp touche en dis
heureusement que je ne suis pas un
décédeur politique
euh parce que justement
euh toute décision est en quelque sorte
mauvaise dans le contexte d'aujourd'hui
ou l'absence de décision et d'ailleurs
je dirais pour celui le
Sénat que la question palestienne a la
démonstration de l'erreur de la théorie
des président cuil qu' n'y a pas de
problème qu'une absence de solution ne
permet de régler un jour ben c'est pas
le cas
euh de ce point de vue il y a en ce qui
concerne israëlpalestine il y a une
hypocrisie internationale ce qu' a fait
la la volonté internationale c'est de
définir le droit par un jeu de
résolution de l'ONU pas seulement la 242
mais en un certain nom d'autres du
Conseil de sécurité en particulier sur
Jérusalem mais aucune des résolutions de
l'enu sont sous le chapitre 3 euh et
c'est volontaire le chapitre 3 c'est
celui qui donne possibilité d'appliquer
par la
force euh dans chapitre 7 oui pardon
c'est l'absus chapitre 7 euh donc vous
pouvez dire définir le droit mais si
vous vous donnez pas les moyens euh de
l'appliquer euh c'est notre probl
euh vous avez sur l'islam parfaitement
raison sur la faiblesse théologique du
sunisme et le combien le salafisme est
un appauvrissement de la théologie euh
mais salfalacisme il a pas né avec
l'Arabie Saoudite il né déjà il y a plus
d'un siècle
euh euh donc cet appauvrissement
intellectuel moral et cetera que
représente le salafisme est une
véritable catastrophe par rapport à la
richesse qu' avait le modernisme euh de
euh la même
période j'ai toujours eu des doutes sur
le fait qu'on mettait le salafisme sur
le dos des Saoudiens même si eux sont de
pratiquement salafites
euh dans la mesure même où le salafisme
existait avant l'Arabie Saoudite il
était déjà diffusé
ailleurs que dans la péninsule arabique
et que bon certes la propagande
saoudienne à un certaine époque a joué
mais ça n'a pas suffi loin de là parce
que ça correspondait à des attentes de
fractions conséquentes euh des
populations ne serait-ce que par ça
simplicité euh le pétrole pas cher en
non l'économie pétrolière était à C une
époque UNEP économie cartellisée et
régulée par les
MAJ en fait la stratégie américaine en
1945 était pas celle-là c'était de
reconstruire l'économie européenne par
le plan Marshal sur le pétrole arabe euh
et ça c'est marqué noir sur bland dans
les pensées des stratèges américaines
1947 l'Europe ne se reconstruira qu'avec
le pétrole du monde arabe il s'agissait
pas d'exporter ce pétrole vers le
continent américain
euh euh donc ça c'est un point euh bon
aujourd'hui
oui il y a des tensions fortes il y a
une question de volonté qui est plus
compliquée que ça monsieur Obam pense
que les États-Unis n'ont pas intérêt à
s'engager dans une guerre et il
enseignent d'en faire le moins possible
ça veut pas dire qu'il ne renonce à tuer
les drones il il les a utilisé
absolument systématiquement et puis
surtout les instruments sont toujours là
euh la question américaine est plus une
question de volonté d'utiliser des
instruments que de nonexistence de C
instruments ça veut dire tout simplement
la 6e flotte elle est toujours en
Méditerranée et la 5e elle est toujours
dans l'océan Indien et le saintcom est
toujours au Qatar
euh donc rien n'a
bouger dans le dispositif
militaire américain même si Obama lui il
aurait préféré déplacer ça vers la mer
de Chine
euh
voilà donc ça veut dire que ses
successeurs parce que maintenant il n'en
a plus que pour 1 an et 10 jours à peu
près euh 8 jours
pardon
donc ces successeurs auront toujours les
mêmes instruments qui neuront pas été
déplacés
et en tout cas pour l'état actuelle de
la campagne électorale américaine même
Madame Clinton c'est bien que les
républicains ont des positions entre
guillemets plus dures dans la campagne
électorale que celle du
président Obama alors pour les Saoudiens
la question c'est aussi la question de
la
succession parce que là elle est entamée
euh puisqu changement de
génération dans la dynastie qui semble
qu'il y a des fortes tensions à
l'intérieur de la famille royale mais on
nen sait pas
plus merci on reviendra peut-être tout à
l'heure sur ce que disait madame Jourdin
je vais laisser la parole à Claude
maluré je vais vous prier de m'excuser
je dois que c'est mon vice-président le
vice-président de notre commission le
premier qui va présider Claude maluret
est-ce que j'interviens après le
changement de présid vas-y vas-y
vas-y monsieur professeur on a beaucoup
de raison d'alimenter les motifs de
désespoir moi je voudrais me poser la
question des éventuels motifs
d'espoir vous nous avez rappelé avec
beaucoup de pertinence la tradition
d'interventionnisme dans la région
elle est tellement développée
aujourd'hui que le monde entier
pratiquement est en train d'intervenir
IR depuis les États-Unis jusqu'à la
Russie et cetera et cetera donc le monde
entier est autour de ce conflit en Syrie
et en Irak et et
au-delà les guerres même les guerres de
30 ans que vous avez cité comme exemple
finissent par se terminer un jour et en
général elle se termine avec les
diplomates alors ma question c'est que
on est aujourd'hui dans une situation où
on sent un frémissement et un retour
pour la première fois de la diplom
e pour différentes pour différentes
raisons vous en avez évoqué certaines
mais et vous avez tout à fait raison
premièrement parce que tous les
protagonistes s'aperçoivent désormais
que la solution qu'il privilégie ne sera
pas adoptée et qu'il va falloir faire
des compromis les Occidentaux par
exemple voit bien qu'ils soutiennent des
rebelles qui au départ étai les
printemps arabe
peut-être démocratique vous avez mis ça
entre guillemets et cetera il s' soiv
que d'une part ils sont sur le recul
depuis l'intervention russe deuxièmement
qu'il se radicaliseent de plus en plus
et que ça pose un problème de
gouvernance futur les Russes et les
Iraniens s'aperçoivent que à grand frais
ils sont en train d'essayer de maintenir
mais que la fin leur solution sur le
maintien du régime Assad est impossible
ils sont en train s'en apercevoir la
deuxième raison c'est celle que vous
avez dit le pétrole avec un prix qui a
été divisé par trois fait que les bellig
gérants locaux n'ont plus les moyens
l'Arabie Saoudie un budget en déficit de
30 % cette année pour la première fois
de son son histoire et cetera et cetera
donc les les Russes évidemment n'ont
plus les moyens avec ce prix du pétrole
et les sanctions de continuer longtemps
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire ils
montrent les muscles actuellement et
tout ils soutiennent le régime mais ça
va pas pouvoir durer longtemps vous
l'avez rappeler donc aujourd'hui tout le
monde est en train de s'apercevoir
localement ou internationalement qu'il
va falloir causer moi j'envoie les
signes je je me permettrai si vous le
voulez d'avoir une petite divergence
avec votre analyse sur
trop d'interventionnisme de Bush et pas
assez d'interventionnisme d'Obama moi je
raconterai l'histoire peut-être en trois
phases trop d'interventionnisme de Bush
encore que sur l'Afghanistan on peut se
demander ce qui serait passé s'il
n'était pas intervenu il y aurait eu un
vivier et un pays pour pour les Taliban
et pour Al-Qaïda mais enfin bon sur
l'Irak d'accord donc trop d'intion de B
pback d'Obama à la suite des échecs de
l'Afghanistan et de l'IRAC mais depuis
quelques quelques mois un retour enfin
il suffit de regarder télé on voit Kerry
depuis quelques mois on voit John Kerry
absolument partout un retour de la
diplomatie américaine et donc de
l'interventionnisme américain sauf que
ça n'est plus sur le plan militaire à
part l'intervention les drones et cetera
mais essentiellement une un accent mis
de façon très très forte sur la
diplomatie et quand la diplomatie
américaine se met en marche évidemment
ça fait d'où euh l'accord sur l'Iran qui
était quand même pas du tout du tout du
tout donné à l'avance qui a été
effroyablement long compliqué mais les
Américains ils sont arrivés vous
interprétez cela en disant ça a relancé
euh évidemment l'antagonisme Iran Arabie
saudite mais en même temps ça a permis
que pour la première fois on commence à
se causer ça a permis la conférence de
Vienne c'est c'est là-dessus que je
voulais renir il y aurait pas eu de
conférence de Vienne s'il n'y avait pas
eu l'accord sur l'Iran et le fait qu'on
ait appris à se parler entre les uns et
les autres même aujourd'hui avec
l'histoire de l'Arabie Saoudite et de
l'Iran qui aurait pu dans un autre
période se se se dérouler sur un thème
très conflict uel aujourd'hui on sent
bien que les dirigeants d'Arabie
Saoudite et d'Iran d'ailleurs le prince
Salman l'a dit textuellement nous
n'allons pas faire la guerre à l'Iran à
cause de ce qui se passe en ce moment
quelle que soit la violence verbale donc
ma question c'est c'est c'est la
suivante est-ce que c'est le fait qu'un
jour ou l'autre il faudra en venir à la
diplomatie est-ce que malgré toutes les
difficultés on n'est pas en train d'
d'arriver à cette phase pour toutes les
raisons que que vous avez que que je
viens de de rappeler euh est-ce qu'il y
a là un motif d'espoir ou est-ce que
vous pensez qu' qu'il va falloir encore
attendre vu la situation sur le terrain
des années et des années pour parvenir à
cela moi je vois quelques perspectives
au niveau de la diplomatie
ou voulez peut-être répondre euh très
rapidement euh vous avez certainement
raison euh d'ailleurs la discussion
qu'il y a de sera un projet de solution
politique à la question sérienne en elle
signne euh et pour le reste tous les
facteurs que vous avez énoncé de plus
vous avez raison parce que dire bu Obama
c'est un peu plus compliqué dans la
mesure où la politique
d'Obama avait suivi celle des dernières
années des président Bush donc la
rupture était moins
forte qu'on l'a pensé parce que c'est
Bou qui a énoncé que les États-Unis
quitteraient
l'Afghanistan et
l'Irak donc de ce point de vue en effet
le position est trop simple moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est la capacité des acteurs
internationaux d'avoir une action sur le
terrain
euh vous avez des dizaines et des
centaines de milices qui se battent
entre en Syrie euh
Irak et si vous n'avez pas
l'intervention de force d'interposition
puissemment armé avec un mandat leur
permettant de se battre euh je vois pas
comme com s forces enfin comment on
pourrait régler la situation concrète en
dans la myriade des petits
acteurs qui sont sur le terrain et je
vois pas où on aura ces dizaines de
milliers de soldats euh prenez l'exemple
du
Kosovo les troupes occidentales ils sont
encore hein
euh donc je veux dire un règlement
politique qui n'implique pas l'envoi de
milliers de soldat sur le terrain ça ne
marchera pas à mon avis mais je vois pas
où on trouvera ses forces
armées merci on va peut-être contenu de
leur regrouper les quatre dernières
questions Michel de Messine tout
d'abord merci monsieur le Président moi
aussi je voudrais remercier Monsieur le
professeur pour la clarté de son propos
c'est surtout son déroulement historique
qui remonte au 19e 19e siècle c'est trè
très intéressant et finalement assez
court pour bien comprendre les choses et
justement je pense que euh ça devrait
permettre de d'avoir une meilleure
vision pour voir quelles sont les
erreurs qu'il ne faudrait pas
recommencer
euh et donc et pour trouver la sortie de
crise que vous pouvez pas que nous
énoncer mais enfin qui qui reste quand
même
la le point le plus important
aujourd'hui euh moi j'aurais deux
questions plus une remarque euh dans
roulement justement vous faites euh peu
référence même si ça a été fait à l' à
l'interaction des enjeux économiques et
notamment la dans cette région-là la non
seulement d'une religion mais aussi euh
la présence de richesses pétrolière et
gazière qui qui font marcher le monde
aussi donc je pense que ça peut-être
aussi important de revenir là-dessus euh
ensuite j'aurais une autre question mais
peut-être vous pour vous pourrez pas
répondre mais en tout cas moi elle me
tarode c'est que on n a pas fini des
conséquences euh de de cette situation
que qui nous mène à la situation
d'aujourd'hui et on vient de découvrir
avec effroid un phénomène nouveau qui
est celui des agressions sexuelles de
masse qui ont existé c'est vrai en
Égypte à laquelle on a fait peu
attention qu'on vient de découvrir là
maintenant à Cologne et qui nous
interpelle vraiment parce que jusqu'où
la dégradation va
et et en plus ça quand même ça complique
encore plus la compréhension de de toute
cette situation et ma dernière remarque
c'est par rapport au au lien que vous
avez fait entre zone de développement et
zone tribal et et en faisant en
réfléchissant au fait mais comment du
coup agréger le phénomène nouveau des
jeunes des banlieu moi je pense que
justement il y a peut-être un lien très
culturel très fort entre communautarisme
et et zones tribal qui pourrait
peut-être mieux
comprendre merci André triard oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Professeur euh j'ai une question qui est
satisfaite parce que je voulais vous
faire parler de l'économie vous vous
avez parlé l' développé j'en ai une
deuxième qui est un rappel que je vous
fais sur les zones tribales
particulièrement au Pakistan et en
Afghanistan puisque c'est un cheval sur
les deux pays ce sont des zones que les
Anglais n'ont pas réussi à civiliser sur
la deuxème partie du 19e siècle mais c
ces zones tribales ont un ont une une
particularité c'est qu'elles sont un
territoire où s'est développé
aujourd'hui je prends l'exemple du
Pakistan la moitié la moitié des enfants
scolarisés le sont dans des écoles
coraniques les madrassas et dans ces
écoles
coraniques je ne pense pas qu'on
apprenne la paix dans ces pays-là donc
ma question est la suivante dans un pays
comme la France je prends le conflit
avec les Allemands sont quand même même
nos dirigeants qui ont dit qu'il fallait
qu'on se réconcilie et qu'on organ qui
ont organisé les choses euh si on
continue à
fournir des futurs combattants par une
éducation qui n'est pas faite
euh le risque ne paraît être sans fin et
je voulais avoir votre avis là-dessus
peut-être assz de questions puis
reprendra les deux dernières pour
conclure effondrement de la rente
pétrolière augmentation du circuit de la
vente d'armes
la Russie visiblement essaie de se
refaire un peu d'argent euh en vendant
massivement euh de l'armement donc dans
l'affaire saenne et aussi une
démonstration euh mais c'est un peu
aussi notre affaire à nous hein on a
démontré les capacités du Rafal ce qui a
permis de aussi d'intéresser un certain
nombre
cette de euh ce point de vue
euh bon l'islam c'est complexe je sais
pas ce que c'est en un sens parce que la
limite l'islam c'est ce qu'on font les
musulmans et que vous avez une variété
considérable de musulmans et donc une
variété considérable euh
d'Islam de ce point de vue en effet
euh vous
avez cet islam qui en quelque sorte un
islam éérité de la fin du 19e siècle
c'est-à-dire la constitution d'un
contreprojet euh par rapport à la
culture occidentale et la domination euh
occidentale un contre-projet
semi-utopique parce que c'est absurde de
vouloir revenir au 7e siècle pour
résoudre les problèmes euh du 21e siècle
euh et c'était une des clés du printants
Aram qui est malheureusement avorté
parce que en 2011- 2012 en tout cas en
Égypte à qui on pouvait démontrer que
l'islam n'était pas la solution et le
coup d'État en Égypte empêché de de
démontrer
euh cela donc de ce point de vue-là ça
n'a pas été bon euh cela dit je vous
rappelle que c'est au lendemain des
guerres de religion que les lumières se
sont allumé en Europe et justement par
rejet de ce qui s'était passé dans les
guerres de religion ce que j'ad on
appelé la crise de conscience européenne
un livre célèbre euh et dans ce
sansela sans pouvoir évidemment de faire
des prédictions dans les boules de
cristal nous avons quand même aussi des
myriades de petits
siges dans les sociétés musulmanes
d'apparition de gens qui contestent la
domination
religieuse la multiplication des
affaires dites de
blasphème les procès d'atteinte à la
religion qui se multiplie bon ce sont
des
indicateurs qui montre que quelque chose
est en train de se produire
euh je peux pas dire plus he je peux pas
vous dire ils vont se laïciser ça j'y
croit pas mais je dire il y avait quand
même des indicateurs qu'il y a quelque
chose euh qui est en train d'émerger
dans ces sociétés qui différent moi
encore une fois ce que je crois c'est
que la volonté la plus élémentaire des
populations qu'elle soit musulmane ou
non c'est de vivre une vie normale et
décente et que c'était le moteur de 2011
et c'est le moteur de la Grande
Migration euh actuel le problème c'est
que nous ne pvons pas le assurer ça en
Europe mais ça c'est un autre
euh sujet en ce qui concerne les
agressions sexuelles vous avez
parfaitement raison c'est des choses qui
étaient très montées en Égypte et qu'on
s'attendait pas à voir venir
euh ici bah ça rappelle un élément
simple simple parce que c'est une
combinaison d'éléments anthropol i et
d'élément économique qui fait que le
freinage démographique de cette région
du monde s'est fait en propulsant l'âge
au mariage au-delà de 30
ans et comme vous mettez en même temps
une morale sexuelle
impitoyable l'un dans l'autre vous créz
une frustration sexuelle absolument
épouvantable qui est un des moteurs de
la violence il suffit de voir d'ailleurs
tout l'aspect sexuel qu'il a dans le
djihadisme pour on voyait ça déjà dans
l'Algérie des années
90 pourvoir évidemment qu'une partie de
cette violence vient de ces ensemble de
frustration et je dois dire aussi que
les migrants ou certains migrants pas
tous les migrants mais certains migrants
passent par de telles épreuves
humaines dans leur traversée vers
l'Europe que certains perdent beaucoup
de Moré moi ça me rappelle le film
magnifique de lAKAZA amé
améric qui raconte l'odysée d'un jeune
arménien vers l'Amérique et finalement
il n arrive à faire des choses
épouvantables pour pouvoir
arriverand ça se passe avant 1914 bah
améric améric c'est un peu aujourd'hui
la
situation de ces populations qui afflu
vers l'Europe et nous avons des gens bah
oui qui perdent
beaucoup en route
merci alors encore deux brèves questions
contenu de l'heure Christian camerman et
Jacques leand Christian merci monsieur
le Président bien sûr la salle est
presque vide c'est la fin et c'est
normal et merci monsieur le professeur
pour cette intéressante réunion je
voulais vous vous j'ai entendu deux mots
de votre part au sujet du Liban c'est
pourtant un pays très important et je
voulais je sais que vous n'avez pas une
boule de cristal à côté de vous pour
répondre aux questions question mais
tout de même je voudrais savoir ce que
vous pensez de l'avenir proche de ce
pauvre pays très touché de par les
années récentes et puis que pensez-vous
aussi d'un avenir
lointain tout à fait récemment nous
sommes allés avec le président du Sénat
quelques personnes quelques sénateurs au
Liban pour demander aux politiques de
bien vouloir faire quelque chose de plus
pour avoir un président de la République
qui manque depuis longtemps et un
gouvernement plus efficace avec un
président du gouvernement qui voulait
s'en aller et que nous avons nous avons
pu lui faire comprendre qu'il fallait
absolument rester le peuple a peur le
Liban est mal placé il y a eu des
ordures qui restent depuis 4 mois donc
ça engendre des maladies beaucoup de
choses beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés pour les Libanais euh
beaucoup de souffrances qui ont été
suivies pendant la guerre et qui
recommencent beaucoup de chômage pas
d'argent et
cetera et dernière question pensez-vous
que le Liban risque de redevenir une
Grande
Syrie c'est tout merci Jacques lejande
enfin comme CIT oui monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues vous avez
souligné dans votre passionante exposé
la différence entre Al-Qaïda et puis
daesh en montrant qu'Al-Qaïda installait
des foyers de terrorisme et que daesh
avait une conception territoriale ne
pensez-vous pas que tout ceci conduira à
remettre en cause les États tels qu'ils
sont géographiquement constitué
actuellement au Moyen-Orient en
particulier ce qui ressort finalement de
quand même des volontés coloniales entre
guillemets la ligne sax Pico et et
cetera est-ce que l'Irak en tant que tel
dans ses frontières a un avenir est-ce
que la Syrie ne verrait pas ses limites
modifié dans un sens ou dans l'autre
est-ce que la Jordanie a une chance
d'exister dans l'avenir euh est-ce qu'il
ne faudra pas débattre de tout ça lors
d'une négociation globale de remise en
ordre de cette
zone bon sur le Liban
euh c'est vraiment les pays qui intégré
le plus le discours de l'ingérence et de
l'application au point qu'on peut dire
que pour tous libanais il y a une
seconde patrie en tout cas pour toute la
classe politique euh libanaise et a une
seconde patrie quelle qu'elle soit
l'Arabie Saoudite niran et cetera euh et
ca et en ce sens-là le jeu politique
libanais et un jeu qui est plus pour les
autres que pour les Libanais eux-mêmes
il suffit de lire la presse libanais
pour voir comment ils intègrent en
permanence ses jeux de relations
internationales ce qui fait que
d'ailleurs le Liban est le seul pays au
monde où les ambassadeurs ont encore une
importance euh suffit aussi de voir la
presse même francophone qui qui vous
indique de ce point de vuelà le seul
motif d'espérance au Liban c'est qu'ils
ont eu la guerre entre 75 et 90 et que
chacune des parties
euh joue une stratégie au bord du goufre
mais n'a pas envie de sauter dans le
gouffre
euh donc il un mécanisme qui les amène à
à arrêé au bord de la catastrophe ce
qu'on peut espérer que c'est ça
euh se euh poursuivre bon les frontières
question classique traditionnelle bon
rappel
pédant Saico non c'est pas sa expico
c'est sans ro parce que les liges sans
Remo c'est très différent des liges sa
expico et d'ailleurs très curieusement
l'État islamique correspond à l'une des
zones des accord sapico géographiquement
parlant c'est assez amusant quand on
compare la carpico et la carte actuelle
c'est pour ça que j'avais fait un papier
ironique en disant com rétabl et non
laabolit
pas donc de ce point de vue là vous avez
deux choses d'abord l'histoire de
l'abolition de la frontière cquen c'est
de la
fouteuse DAEs Irak est composé
exclusivement
d'Irakiens Syrie est composé
majoritairement de non syrien
euh donc on voit tout de suite que la
frontière fonctionne et d'ailleurs vous
avez toujours des gens qui font des
droit de Douine ou des raquettes à la
frontière même si elle a été euh
abolie la Jordanie bon si vous ouvrez
les archives vous verrez que depuis 50
ans 60 ans les gens diront la Jordanie
ça mérite pas d'exister ça doit ça va
logiquement disparaître dans 10 ans si
vous ouvrez la bibliographie vous verrez
le nombre d'ouvrages qui V expliquer que
l'Arabie Saoudite ça peut pas tenir et
ça va disparaître dans les 5 ans
euh à
venir donc ça fait des décennies que ces
gens sont censés disparaître dans les
années à venir et ils sont toujours là
ce qui m'è de revenir sur la question
CDE en effet les CDES oui là il y a un
facteur éventuel de changement
déplacement de frontière mais
apparemment on n'y va pas
euh parce que la Turquie euh qui est
plutôt allié avec les curdes d'Irak
plutôt style le CD de Syrie enfin bon
euh mais quand même son interdiction à
la constitution d'un État curde Bagdad
n'en veut pas non plus euh il y a des
c'est pas aussi évident que ça qu' a un
état curde en revanche dans une cas
d'une solution politique vous pu avoir
des structures de extrêmement forte
autonomie
euh donc dans le règlement politique on
peut imaginer en effet des vastes
mouvements de décentralisation politique
à l'intérieur des frontière
héritiè de la Première Guerre mondiale
ça c'est logique ce qui est plus
inquiétant sur le terrain c'est pas la
remise en cause des frontières ce sont
les déplacements de population en Syrie
et en Irak qui tendent à être des
nettoyages ethniques ou confessionnel ou
religieux ce que vous voulez et euh ça
va plutôt dans une approche
d'accélération
euh ces derniers mois donc on imagine
très mal le retour de
population dans des zones où elles ont
été chassées parce que que les rapports
avec les gens qui occupent le
terrain et qui sont armés ne seront
pas faciles et encore une fois on voit
pas comment les gens peuvent revenir si
vous n'avez pas une présence militaire
internationale extrêmement forte de
dizaines de milliers d'hommes armés et
encore une fois je sais pas où on peut
euh les
trouver ce qui a des risques terrible
c'est de voir des populations entières
massacré dans les mois à venir en Syrie
qu'elle soit sunnite alaouite ou autre
parce que si vous les exposz pas sous
forme d'migrant bah vous allez les
massacrer vous passez par des formes
comme l'utilisage de la famine
euh comme on a pu voir un certain nombre
de cas dans les affaires syriennes
d'aujourd'hui alors en conclusion je
voudrais reprendre des formules qui sont
pratiquement celles du sapeur camamber
même ce sont pas euh du sapeur camamber
mais qui résume à peu près la situation
tout est dans tout et réciproquement euh
don la région c'està dire que vous êtes
pas isolé à facteur parce que tout est
absolument
entremêlé et la seconde formule c'est
quand on passe les bornes il y a plus de
limite or on a passé les bornes et d'ù
l'extrême violence les massacres les
destructions les pertes d'humanité euh
dans lequel enfin face auquel nous
sommes euh
aujourd'hui merci monsieur le professeur
de avoir donné un éclairage je sais pas
si on peut puiser dans vos propos des
éléments d'espérance pour demain mais
enfin disons que euh on y aura trouvé un
peu plus de connaissance pour nous
retrouver et et mieux comprendre ce qui
s'y passe et merci aussi de la dimension
historique car je crois que dans une
région qui est secoué par autant de
sousbressau il est toujours important de
regarder comment les choses sont
arrivées merci infiniment de nous avoir
fait l'honneur de cette communication
merci mes chers
collègues je vous remercie de votre
invitation je vous en